okay so with the batman now upon us i
thought i'd revisit the film that's not
only held up as the benchmark movie for
the character but also the genre as a
whole released almost 15 years ago the
dark knight completely revolutionized
the medium and it influenced so many
films for the next 10 years that it's
difficult to discredit it i absolutely
love the dark knight and upon leaving
the cinema i remember feeling completely
overwhelmed on a number of levels not
only was it a great achievement in terms
of storytelling but there was also a lot
of sadness around the passing of heath
ledger who completely knocked out the
park with his oscar-winning performance
he's someone who's been immortalized
because of this movie and to this day
his betrayal is still something that i'm
blown away by whatever doesn't kill you
simply makes you
stranger
he is the perfect opposite to batman
throughout the film whereas he brings
chaos batman tries to restore everything
through order this is a motif that
massively plays into the ending and why
bruce makes the choices that he does now
throughout this video i really want to
analyze that final scene the build up to
it and all the elements at play that
make it a masterpiece i'd of course love
to hear your thoughts and if you agree
then make sure you smash the thumbs up
button and also don't forget to
subscribe for videos like this every day
without the way this is the heavy
spoiler show i'm your host paul now
let's get into the dark knight
okay so in order to understand why the
ending works so well we have to very
much analyze the psychology of batman
and his overall goals when bruce was
very young his parents were murdered in
front of him and since then he spent
every day trying to make sure that this
never happens to anyone else the death
of the waynes was very much a chance
encounter and though this has been
recontextualized in recent properties
like the joker whether you think they
were good or bad bruce was very much a
victim in this too chaos ripped the best
things in his life from him and since
then he's honed his body to bring order
to gotham the city that destroyed his
life now batman begins ends with him
saving his hometown from the clutches of
raz al ghul very authoritary
though father's name was pronounced race
not raz a common mistake i'm just going
to call him raz as it's in line with the
films but yeah the pronunciation of it
is often disputed however the ending of
begins is very much an opposite to the
dark knight and they in many ways mirror
one another begins ends with batman
meeting gordon and the ladder shows him
that he's somewhat being accepted by the
city due to the creation of the bat
signal this will shine over gotham and
let criminals know there's a force
within it to be reckoned with that won't
allow them to prey on the good people
any longer because batman acts
anonymously and in a mask it inspires
criminals to do the same thing too
whether he likes it or not batman
creates the joker because of this and it
very much leads the city into an even
more terrifying situation for the sequel
throughout he watches the dark knight
and joker battle it out in gotham as
they constantly try and one-up the other
batman puts a tight grip on the finances
of the mob and because of this they
turned the clan prince of crime to take
him down however he realizes that things
have changed and there's now no going
back
but i know the truth there's no going
back you've changed things
rather than killing batman he'd rather
keep him alive so that the two can
battle it out as they fight for the soul
of gotham now this very much is
represented by harvey dent early on
bruce encounters copycats and hockey
pads which i swear wasn't intentionally
a rhyme but we'll keep it in here copy
cats in hockey pads i like that but i'm
not a rapper now he realizes that they
are somewhat just as chaotic as the
things that he's trying to prevent and
therefore gotham needs a face it can
shine in the light a white knight who
does things by the books this comes in
the form of harvey who's very much an
idealist happy to face the mob face to
face to face to face he's very much what
bruce sees for the future of gotham
rather than having people who operate in
the dark like he does he needs someone
who will stand in the firing line and
say not on my watch a joker realizes
this too and he starts to formulate a
plan that will destroy not only harvey
but also batman joker kills rachel dawes
harvey's fiancee and the woman that
batman loves after figuring out that
they have a connection bruce shows that
he's the best of them because he doesn't
succumb to her death turning him into a
monster we'll talk about this later on
but rachel's death is very much an
attempt at the joker getting two birds
with one stone i think come the end of
the movie he realizes that batman is
incorruptible this is why harvey is very
much his ace in the hole as throughout
the movie he's been propped up as the
shining white light of the city he's
stood in courtrooms and taking guns
being pointed at him announced he was
batman to draw the joker out and
throughout he's been happy to put his
face forward joker isn't able to beat
batman and thus instead he decides to
destroy his plan of propping up citizens
as those who can take down corruption
bruce says in begins he wants to create
a symbol to shake people out of apathy
and dent will very much be an example of
what they can be if they strive to
improve things not to do a coin pun but
they're very much opposite sides of the
same one and whereas batman does work on
many levels bruce knows he can't
completely work because he can't put
himself forward as a person that people
can see themselves truly becoming
because of this i think that the joker's
plan is genius but on the flip side of
this batman's retaliation is as equally
clever now i absolutely love how the
dark knight has two climaxes firstly we
get the amazing showdown in the building
with the joker in which he flips the
script and makes his forces dress up as
hostages and vice versa he also sets up
the prisoner and civilian boat situation
that tries to show from a ground level
how the villain has the potential to
corrupt even the most boring and bland
day-to-day businessman almost though
yeah and i know i know you weren't gonna
do it and he said to dogs on batman and
almost goes out laughing whilst falling
to his death and delivers a monologue
that gives me goosebumps every time i
watch it joker hanging upside down shows
he is very much the opposite to batman
and it's the perfect way to close out
the rock together this is what happens
when an unstoppable force
meets
an immovable object
but it isn't the end and across town he
watches harvey holds gordon's family at
gunpoint whilst he menacingly flips a
coin batman arrives and though he
defeats dent it seems like everything
they've been fighting for is at a loss
like gordon says they bet it all on him
and the people will lose hope however
batman instead decides to take the fall
because he's the hero that the city
deserves but not the one that it needs
the people need to believe that they can
be like dent and thus batman takes the
blame
we better all on him
the joker took the best of her centaurum
now
people will lose hope
they won't
they must never know what he did
now i don't know if it's the hands in
the score the incredible editing by
nolan or just the gravitas of the scene
but i pretty much can feel all the hairs
on my arms and neck standing up whenever
i watch this moment they could reveal
the truth that harvey was corrupted but
like batman says sometimes the truth
isn't good enough and people deserve
more thus the pair prop up the lie that
it was batman who killed those people
and the gotham police department chase
him through the night at this point gary
oldman drops one of the best monologues
to close out a movie ever
[Music]
a watchful protector
a dark knight
now at this point as he writes off we
see bruce traveling up a ramp into the
light showing the ascension that the
character has batman is now fully a
symbol that can take the blame for
things in order to restore gotham to the
height of prevalence that it needs to be
not only does this beat the joker but it
also gives gotham a moderate rally
behind that will allow the good people
to band together in order to fight evil
it's the perfect way to close out the
film and it shows the true sacrifice of
what it means to be a hero batman is
something that can be destroyed and take
it down because it will help proper this
up and inspire those in gotham to do
right when it's much easier to do wrong
though this would have been a difficult
choice for anyone else bruce puts
himself in the firing line because he
can take it and though he'll be hounded
others will be able to have a better
life because of it all he's ever wanted
to do is inspire the city to save itself
by saving the image of their white
knight he's made it so that people can
rally together and lift gotham out the
dirt it's an incredible way to end the
movie that shows the strength of batman
on a number of levels he can be the hero
but he can also be something more a
silent guardian that much like those
that the romans appointed to protect the
city looks over as a watchful protector
i absolutely love the way that the movie
closes out and it perfectly builds on
the themes and plot points of this film
and begins to deliver a home run as
bruce runs home and i thought my jokes
were bad
anyway that's the video yeah i hope you
enjoyed us taking a trip down memory
lane to talk about the dark knight and
that i didn't ruin your day with a
terrible joke at the end on screen right
now we have some more perfect scene
videos including one discussing why the
andrew garfield won in spider-man know a
home means so much as always i've been
your spoiler guardian your watchful
protector and i'll see you on the next
one take care peace